قال الامين العام لحزب الله اللبنانيه حسن
نصر الله ان اي تسويف في استخراج النفط
والغاز من المياه اللبنانيه سيقابل بمنع
اسرائيل من استخراج النفط والغاز من حقل
كاريش واضاف نصر الله في كلمه خلال احتفال
حزبي ان هناكنيات مبيته للتسويف في موضوع
استخراج الغاز من الحقول اللبنانيه داعيا
الحكومه الى اتخاذ قرار جريء على حد وصفه
ليش اذا حدا مفكر انه اذا بصير تسويف
بموضوع
استخراج النفط والغاز من المياه اللبنانيه
وعن جد بنكتشف نحن انه في تسويف وفي لعب
على اللبنانيين في ضحك على اللحى حنسبح
يضلوا يستخرجوا نفطوا غاز من كاويش انا
بالكون ابدا
هلا في ناس اخذوها ان نحكي انفعال لا انا
كنت مفكر منيح بالكلمه هذا معنى اذا بدك
تجوعني بقتلك
هذا بحذر الامين العام لحزب الله
اللبنانيه حسن نصر الله من ان دفع البلاد
نحو الفوضى من خلال ازمه الاقتصاديه سيؤدي
الى امتداد هذه الفوضى الى كل المنطقه
حسبت تعبيره
اذا دفعتم لبنان
الى ستخسرون في لبنان وعليكم ان تنتظروا
الفوضى في كل المنطقه
عندما تمتد
مؤامراتكم الى اليد التي تؤلمنا وهي ناسنا
سنمد ايدينا وسلاحنا الى اليد التي تؤلمكم
وهي وبيبتكم